dear mum
i have to figure out who i really am i'm
sorry for leaving
but i knew that you were trying to stop
hello darling
dear mom i'm sorry for leaving again
the world is a scary place but i can
look after myself mum
when it comes to girls you've always
been a duck out of water
well it's completely fine then what
don't worry
i want you to have some fun you have to
speak to the next woman who walks in
this one whoever they are
i thought it would be nice to come for a
drink here with dad oh is he coming down
you're leaning on him oh god i'm so
i'm so sorry fun thought let's say it is
the end of the world and we all have two
weeks to live what would you do
eat donuts and try and have sex with
people all right go on kim what about
you
um
hello jimmy you killed my dad
remember me kim's have been a long time
what so why is that going to happen
there's two dead people we need to leave
bro what's happening who are they why
are they attacking you
okay we're trapped in a house with some
weirdo who thinks it's the end of the
world
she's not a weirdo you don't even know
her i know well enough
i'll drive you shoes what do you want us
to do oh i don't know maybe just take
care of saying the [ __ ] out of my face i
really appreciate it
what's going on jimmy's inside man
if he gets half a chance he'll kill
every single one of us
would anyone like a chocolate finger wow
[Applause]
this is the world that you're so
desperate to explore
you lied to me mum my whole life is
alive
your needs are help love makes you do
stupid [ __ ]
nikki
excuse me
you